[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans le 7-8
week-end sur tv 78 votre émission pour
être au fait de l'actualité locale
connaître aussi les événements à venir
nous sommes le vendredi 10 septembre
voici le sommaire
les électeurs de trappes devront
retourner aux urnes les 10 et 17 octobre
après l'annulation du scrutin de 2020 le
maire déchu ali rabais othman nassr où
seront sur la ligne de départ mais
d'autres candidats également qui
sont-ils reportage à suivre
ce samedi les états unis quand même en
rond le douloureux souvenir des
attentats du 11 septembre 2001 qui ont
fait de 1977 victime cette année encore
et des pompiers des yvelines seront à
new york en hommage aux nombreux soldats
du feu américains disparus dont le
lieutenant colonel sébastien frémont qui
est notre invité
est la deuxième partie de cette émission
consacrée aux loisirs début de la saison
à la commanderie de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines randonnée à
faire dans le département et nos idées
de sorties à suivre dans le 7-8 week end
et c'est bixente mayence insisté ban qui
viendra vous présenter sa sélection tout
à leur bonjour bixente comment ça va
bonjour ça va très bien et vous ça va
très bien on est en place pour ce 7 8
week-end et notamment tout à l'heure
vous viendrez nous donner l'envié de
monter sur les planches pour copains oui
on parlera de l'après mai première
édition d'un festival ça s'appelle les
petites scènes de la guyane on aura
d'ailleurs comme invité la metteur en
scène et organisatrice tatiana vialle
mais restez avec nous c'est tout à
l'heure dans le sais tu ce week-end
l'actualité d'abord après l'annulation
de l'élection municipale de 2020 attrape
un nouveau scrutin partiel sera organisé
les 10 et 17 octobre prochains est les
candidats sont d'ores et déjà mobilisés
pour un mode campagne tour d'horizon
avec bixente mayence anti steban et
wilfrid richy
ils sont cinq à s'être officiellement
déclaré candidat aux nouvelles élections
municipales organisées à trappes parmi
eux le maire dont la victoire a été
invalidée en août dernier à irabé les
aussi son principal opposant othman
nassr où ce dernier s'était incliné avec
sa liste avec moins de 3 % d'écart en
2020 dès que les trappistes auront la
tête à l'élection municipale ou début
septembre j'irai vers eux pour
m'exprimer leur expliquer la situation
faire le bilan aussi d'un an de travail
et au service des trappistes il faut
avoir cela en tête en moins d'un an nous
avons réussi à la fois un rétablir le
soutien scolaire à mettre en place la
semaine des quatre jours à baisser le
prix de la cantine par exemple pour les
enfants notamment les plus modestes et
pour les classes moyennes moi je défends
un projet encore il faudra sur l'emploi
sur la jeunesse sur la sécurité sur les
questions de santé sur la bonne gestion
et on voit que c'est un vrai sujet de la
bonne gestion je défends ce projet
depuis des années maintenant sur les
qualités du logement donc je vais me
battre pour que ce projet là soit
adoptée par une majorité des trappistes
qui iront effectivement se mobiliser
parce que le vrai sujet que nous avons
c'est un sujet de mobilisation des
électeurs contacté par notre rédaction
guy malandain ancien maire de trappes de
2001 à 2020 présent au second tour des
dernières élections n'a pas encore
indiqué son choix la question d'un
rapprochement avec othman nasri serait
envisagé trois autres listes ont elles
d'ores et déjà annoncé leur
participation
portées par luc miserait la liste rappaz
gauche défend un projet décliné autour
de douze priorités santé logement
travail ou encore éducation sont
présents la question de l'accompagnement
des personnes et pas simplement de
celles qui sont en difficulté mais
particulièrement de celles qui sont en
difficulté se présente de manière
accru par rapport à l'ensemble des crise
que l'on traverse et qui n'épargne pas
notre ville problème d'éducation
il nous semble qu'il faut aller beaucoup
plus loin que ce qui est proposé aussi
bien d'un point de vue qualitatif que
dans la diversité des propositions pour
représenter l'extrême gauche une liste
menée par patrick plan qu il veut faire
valoir la lutte ouvrière cruellement le
camp des travailleurs n'est pas
représentée dans ces élections et
aujourd'hui faire entendre ce camp des
gens qui sont opprimés qui sont
exploités et qui font tourner dans la
société bien évidemment c'est
indispensable
c'est très intéressant de discuter
aujourd'hui parce que on rencontre une
forte sympathie pour cette cette idée
qui va falloir se défendre et organiser
tous ensemble contre les mauvais coups
du patronat et du gouvernement pour
finir une candidature à deux visages
présents aux élections départementales
robert naga retina mais son frère
ronsard portent ensemble la liste
ensemble pour l'environnement et
l'économie solidaire
parmi leurs idées la protection des
parcs et l'abaissement du prix du ticket
de bus à 1 euro tout simplement parce
que nous sommes proches proche de la
population on écoute on voulait que tous
les jours et en plus nous sommes depuis
longtemps l'habitude attrape presque 35
ans ont vécu à trappes on étudie à
trappes dont on coûte à toute la
population on l'écouté qu'est ce qu'on
va faire a continué à faire partir par
qu'on continue notre marché en continue
à expliquer à nos idées comme combat
commun mentionné par tous les candidats
la lutte contre l'absentéisme des
électeurs de trappes invités aux urnes
les 10 et 17 octobre prochains lors du
second tour des municipales en 2020
seuls 34% des électeurs s'étaient rendus
aux urnes
de son côté le groupe local de la france
insoumise a décidé de ne pas présenter
de candidat pour ce scrutin partiel une
décision prise par les militants au
cours d'une assemblée communale pas de
soutien non plus à othman menace rooney
ali rabais le maire sortant le maire
déchu ni à deux consignes de vote mais
les deux chefs de file de chefs de file
ont été nommés pour s'investir
éventuellement dans une troisième voie
d'union populaire écoutez ses
explications
avec d'éventuels candidats qui se
présenteraient on est
on est mandaté pour discuter au nom de
la france insoumise de trappes
pour un éventuel
d'éventuels actes de candidature sur une
liste ou de soutien de toute façon il
n'y aura pas un soutien officiel
de la france un soumise à aucun candidat
par contre s'il ya une liste
indépendante se présenterait
libre aux commandes de la france
insoumise de s'inscrire sur cette liste
mais à titre individuel voilà ce qu'on
pouvait vous dire sur cette élection
partielle qui se profile à trappes
scrutin les 10 et 17 octobre prochains
alors que le procès des attentats du 13
novembre 2015 a débuté cette semaine en
france les états unis aussi rouvre une
page douloureuse de leur histoire ce
samedi ce seront les 20 ans du 11
septembre 2001 est depuis cette date 1
pompiers des yvelines le lieutenant
colonel sébastien frémont participent
aux hommages sur place il a créé une
association pour venir en aide aux
veuves et enfants des pompiers morts à
new york et a co écrit également un
livre sur le sujet dont la sortie est
imminente entretien enregistré ce jeudi
9 septembre
et je suis avec le lieutenant colonel
sébastien frémont bonjour bonjour qui
est depuis new york où il va suivre donc
les 20 ans de ces commémorations des
attentats du 11 septembre on le rappelle
11 septembre 2001 quatre attentats
suicide qui avaient fait 2009 177
victimes
343 sapeurs pompiers dans la ville de
new york un touché sur les tours du
world trade center déjà tous les deux
ans sébastien primant vous participez à
aux commémorations du 11-septembre vous
avez même créé une association dont on
va parler dans un instant pourquoi ça
vous tient à coeur de retourner sur
place et de participer à ces
commémorations en fait j'y participe
tous les ans depuis 2002 je n'en ai
loupé qu'une malheureusement à ce jour
qui est celle des de l'année dernière
compte tenu de la pandémie où on ne
pouvait pas se rendre à new york même
cette année au demeurant il a fallu que
nous fassions une mission officielle
pour pouvoir nous y rendre parce que ça
n'était pas imaginable en tout cas
c'était pas concevable en ce qui nous
concerne ne pas pouvoir assister
particulièrement cette année à
l'occasion du 20e anniversaire des
attentats du 11-septembre et pas pouvoir
venir commémorer à côté de nos frères
d'armes cette année particulière donc
oui je viens à titre personnel depuis
2002 disait ge
et tout est parti d'une association que
nous avons créée au lendemain des
attentats dès le 12 septembre 2001 en
réalité 3 étions trois collègues des
yvelines qui avions déjà des amis parmi
des pompiers américains et à new york en
particulier et par conséquent
immédiatement s'était mis à collecter de
l'argent on ne savait pas ce constat de
cet argent mais rapidement ça a débouché
sur le souhaite vouloir réaliser une
opération du coeur qui s'est concrétisée
six mois plus tard au mois de mars 2002
en faisant venir 53 membres de familles
de pompiers en deuil et donc des veuves
des orphelins
et puis des membres des familles ne
serait ce que pour encadrer ces aux gens
pour les sortir finalement de leur
quotidien et de ce marasme il vivait et
pour les accueillir au sein des familles
de pompiers des yvelines l'idée c'était
bel et bien comme je le disais une
opération du coeur donc on les a
hébergés dans nos familles et cette
association elle s'appelle fdn y est spé
soixante dix huit vous le dites vous
continuer de venir sur place et de vous
impliquer au sein de cette association
c'est important de s'impliquer sur le
long terme justement vous le dites et uc
victime 343 il ya aussi des conséquences
à plus long terme de ces attentats oui
c'est d'autant plus important de
s'inscrire dans cette dure et que
malheureusement aujourd'hui 20 ans après
le drame du 11 septembre 2001 on
continue de mourir des conséquences de
cet attentat de ces attentats
tout simplement parce que les sauveteurs
les pompiers les policiers et toute
cette communauté de sauveteurs qui s'est
engagé sur les lieux pour tenter de
sauver un maximum de personnes qui se
trouvaient dans les tours par la suite
on continuer à y travailler
d'abord pour tenter de retrouver les
victimes puis pour déblayer le site ce
qui fait que pendant des semaines et des
mois et ils ont travaillé et il dit ont
surtout respirer des substances
extrêmement toxique l'air ambiant était
composé de deux métaux lourds y compris
d'ailleurs de substances radioactives
parce qu'il faut savoir que les tours
jumelles la technologie de l'époque des
années 1970 en matière de détection
incendie
chaque détecteur
contenait une source radioactive ce qui
fait que plusieurs années après certains
ont commencé à développer des maladies
des cancers des insuffisances
respiratoires et qui malheureusement au
fil des ans ont décimé leur rang ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui dans quelques jours
20 ans exactement après le drame en ce
qui concerne les pompiers on déplore
deux cent cinquante six pompiers
supplémentaires qui sont morts en plus
des 343 qui sont décédés ce le jour même
alors pour aussi ses 20 ans de ces
commémorations du 11 septembre 2001 vous
avez écrit un livre avec marc le guélaff
marque bida frédéric arrou la préface
est signée de jules naudet qui était sur
place qui est l'un des rares à avoir eu
des images sur place puisqu'il était en
train de réaliser un documentaire à ce
moment là parlez nous de ce projet
commence et il monte c'est il concrétisé
par les no 6 du contenu de celui il ya
beaucoup de photos notamment que vous
avez réalisé depuis vos nombreux voyages
à new york
c'est ça vous avez étudié grégory
effectivement j'ai la chance que jules
naudet m'accorde son amitié et que par
conséquent il m'a également fait
confiance pour accepter non seulement
pour effacer cet ouvrage mais finalement
quelque chose de beaucoup plus important
qui est une exclusivité de ce livre est
finalement le coeur et l'âme de cet
ouvrage il a il a accepté de me raconter
son septembre
ainsi que les jours et les années qui
ont suivi
jules étant bien sûr lui même à
survivants ne les ayant eu la chance de
ne pas être blessé physiquement en
revanche a été blessé les blessures de
l'âme ça se mesurent moins bien c'est
moins mesurable pour autant les seins
bien réel et ça a été compliqué de
sortir de deux de ce syndrome du
survivant
et donc il m'a accordé sa confiance pour
me raconter tout ça ce qui a permis d'en
décrire un chapitre complet dans cet
ouvrage donc c'est vraiment l'âme du
livre à côté de cela effectivement il ya
c'est un livre d'image
malgré ce texte important dans le
chapitre qui est consacrée à jules mais
sinon c'est principalement
on revient sur les 20 ans qui se sont
écoulés sur les cérémonies comme je le
disais en effet auquel je participe
pratiquement tous les ans sur
l'évolution des potiers de new york
puisque sirleaf qui a orienté sur les
pompiers de new york ce sont les
pompiers new york au travers la tragédie
du 11 septembre 2001 est donc surtout
vingt ans après et bien sûr un autre
aspect important du livre qui est celui
dont on vient de parler qui est le fait
que parmi leurs rangs on continue de
décéder des conséquences de cet attentat
merci lieutenant colonel sébastien
frémont depuis new york d'avoir été avec
nous je rappelle qu'on pied des yvelines
également chef de prévention 11 10 78
merci d'avoir été avec nous je vous en
prie
c'est ma commémoration du 11 septembre
2001 qui viennent clôturer une semaine
dans son actualité retour sur les faits
marquants en 78 secondes et c'est avec
mélanie poker
dans l'actualité cette semaine le procès
des attentats du 13 novembre 2015 s'est
ouvert le 8 septembre 1800 partie civile
pour la plus grande audience criminelle
jamais organisée parmi les victimes des
yvelinois
depuis le 3 septembre l'activité de
l'usiné renault de flins est suspendue
en raison d'une pénurie mondiale de semi
conducteurs en provenance d'asie
près d'un million d'euros de subventions
de la région de france pour la création
de l'éco quartier de gally à versailles
il devrait sortir de terre d'ici 2027
600 élèves ont fait leur rentrée dans le
nouveau collège de mantes la jolie situé
au coeur du val fourré l'établissement
est un projet pédagogique pilote porté
par les événements l'académie de
versailles
après une édition annulé en 2020
l'électrique parc était de retour pour
ce 11e rendez vous les organisateurs
avaient vu les choses en grand en deux
jours de concerts
le multiplexe de cinéma ne verra
finalement pas le jour à maurepas
l'information a été confirmée dans le
courant de l'été un projet
définitivement abandonnée en raison de
la crise qu vide
et bébel n'est plus jean paul belmondo
est décédé ce lundi 6 septembre à l'âge
de 88 ans le comédien avait passé une
partie de son enfance à clairefontaine
et puis le retour d'un rendez vous aviez
connu la saison dernière sur tv 78 légal
checking pour vérifier ce que disent les
acteurs de l'actualité vincent couronne
du collectif des surligneurs décrypte
aujourd'hui une proposition d'arnaud
montebourg candidat à la prochaine
élection présidentielle
l'élection présidentielle approchant les
promesses commencent à fuser et avec
elles leur lot d'incertitudes juridiques
c'est le cas de celle d'arnaud
montebourg qui a déclaré sa candidature
à l'élection présidentielle
le week-end dernier depuis sa ville de
clamecy dans la nièvre arnaud montebourg
envisage je le cite que l'état rachète
le million de biens immobiliers vacants
et le très faible valeur qu'il a
identifiés et les cèdent à ceux qui
veulent s'y installer à condition qu'ils
le remettent en état fin de citation or
il ya un gros obstacles juridiques posés
par le conseil constitutionnel il y a
plus de 30 ans l'état n'a pas le droit
de faire des cadeaux aux personnes c'est
une question d'égalité un cadeau de
l'état à certains serait injuste à
l'égard des autres mais il ya une
exception si le don se fait avec une
contrepartie c'est d'ailleurs ce que
suggère arnaud montebourg 1 les
bénéficiaires remettrait la maison en
état en y faisant des travaux mais il y
a un problème encore ici c'est une fois
que les da a cédé le bien il lui
difficile d'exiger des travaux de remise
en l'état parce que tout simplement il
n'est plus le propriétaire et que fera
arnaud montebourg si les propriétaires
actuels de ces biens ne veulent pas
vendre pour à les exproprier certes mais
c'est une procédure très lourde très
encadré très longue et puis il ya le
coup rien que l'annoncent ce rachat
ferait inévitablement monter les prix de
ces biens écrire et même une spéculation
et cela aussitôt qu'arnaud montebourg
serait déclarée élue c'est déjà arrivé
avec la promesse de françois mitterrand
de nationaliser des banques et des
grandes entreprises en 1981 bilan une
promesse qui devra emprunter un chemin
étroit qui coûtera cher et qui sera
longue très longue à tenir mais
peut-être que ça permettrait enfin à la
france de respecter ses propres lois sur
le droit au logement
si l'enfer peut-être bave pavé de bonnes
intentions les bonnes intentions elles
doivent parfois traverser les enfers
c'est l'heure de votre page loisirs dans
le sais tu ce week-end bixente mayence
insisté ban est de retour en plateau
pour vous donner envie de sortir samedi
à dimanche et à l'heure où les
festivités reprennent petit à petit dans
le 78 la saison de la commanderie situe
l encours comment ce week-end oui depuis
trois ans le lieu est destiné à faire
vivre culture loisirs événements en tous
genres de saint quentin en yvelines les
festivités débutent demain samedi 11
septembre je vous propose du coup de
découvrir ce qui vous attend un
reportage avec la voix d'antoine durant
la commanderie d'elancourt ouvre à
nouveau ses portes la saison sera lancée
samedi de 17h à minuit par un moment de
partage et de festivités avec pour mot
d'ordre les retrouvailles on a tellement
hâte de vraiment relancer une nouvelle
saison qui on l'espère va se j'ai
déroulé au mieux mais de retrouver aussi
les artistes et nos intervenants qu'on
n'a pas trop vu de pierre mans et demi
pour l'occasion l'intégralité de
l'espace extérieur de la commanderie
sera occupée il suffit de faire un petit
retour en arrière pour avoir un aperçu
de la soirée on va avoir d'abord un tout
une partie entre 17h et 20h de
différentes propositions artistiques en
continu dire comme ça voilà avec du
théâtre avec la compagnie des filles
simone avec de la jonglerie avec des
impromptus dans ces deux-là de la
compagnie cfb 451 et puis après on a
donné carte blanche arthur pérol
chorégraphe de la compagnie f pour nous
concocter tout un programme de 20 heures
à minuit la soirée se clôturera en
dansant avec la présence d'un dj un
programme d'ouverture complet qui laisse
présager d'une saison 2021 2022 tout
aussi mouvementé l'idée c'est de faire
vivre ce lieu avec vraiment toutes
sortes de propositions en sciences on
danse en art et tous les publics sur
tout ce qui est important aussi pour
nous c'est d'accueillir ans du plus
jeune au plus vieux de croiser les
publics aussi parmi les grandes dates de
ce début de saison les journées du
patrimoine les 18 et 19 septembre la
nuit blanche le 2 octobre prochain et le
village de la science les 9 et 10
octobre
ont poursuivi cheptel est une première
du côté des mesnuls oui ça s'appelle les
petites scènes de la guyane un festival
de théâtre de lecture animée destiné au
tout public à ce propos tatiana vialle
organisatrice et metteuse en scène y
vient de nous rejoindre pour nous en
parler bonjour donc tatiana tout d'abord
comment est né ce festival alors ce
festival il est né d'une expérience que
j'ai fait l'année dernière avec un
spectacle qui devait se créer au rond
point et j'avais envie de qu'il était
joué une fois avant d'arriver au théâtre
du rond point et donc j'ai décidé de
faire une représentation mais nul qui
m'ont village donc c'était exécuteur 14
avec swann arlaud et et ça a été très
bien accueilli et je me suis dit en fait
les gens sont heureux qu'on leur apporte
des spectacles là où ils vivent voilà on
a l'impression qu'on a moins envie de se
déplacer qu'avant peut-être à cause de
ce padduc auvitu sa fille de donc ça
commence dès ce soir avec notamment un
cabaret en fin de soirée que vous mettez
enseignements oui absolument donc ça
commence en fait à 19 heures avec un
petit
une lecture en ouverture et puis alain
guillard qui a un philosophe forain qui
va venir parler des déchets je pense que
ça va être assez joyeux et puis voilà on
enchaînera avec un cabaret que j'ai mis
en scène et et demain il ya des lectures
commence parce que la grosse journée
c'est surtout demain avec beaucoup de
choses hein on retrouve toute la journée
comme vous avez dit les lectures animées
à 20h30 aussi le spectacle my à une voix
c'est une comédie musicale c'est ça
c'est une comédie musicale sur une
poétesse américaine s'appelle my angel
où il ya cinq femmes sur scène qui
chante danse et c'est un spectacle tout
public à partir de 8 ans ça finit en
soirée en musique des services a fini en
musique avec petit prince un groupe qui
s'appelle petit prince voilà
du coup bien sûr après le concert de
clôture qui s'appelle à l'année
prochaine le rendez-vous en 2022 et déjà
donné c'est ça il y aura une seconde
édition pas en tout cas on va tout faire
pour oui on a envie que de pérenniser ce
festival et qui deviennent annuel qu'est
ce qui fera que ce serait une réussite
cette première édition c'est que
justement les gens retrouvent le plaisir
de venir vous le dites il ya eu un
contexte particulier c'est que les gens
reviennent absolument c'est que les gens
reviennent c'est que c'est que les gens
aient envie de découvrir des artistes
qui connaissent pas voilà la
programmation est assez varié aussi des
choses pour les tout petits un très beau
spectacle de du tas d'objets
voilà donc je pense qu'il y en a
vraiment il ya des propositions pour
tout le monde maintenant on va voir si
les gens ont envie de venir merci
beaucoup tatiana vialle d'avoir été avec
nous pour toutes les informations du tad
vous pourrez retrouver sur le site
sortir en yvelines point fr merci
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle vous
êtes organisatrice et metteuse en scène
de la première édition du festival les
petites les petites haines de la guyane
je vous libère maintenant d'ailleurs
puisque vous devez vous rendre
directement au festival pour préparer
les derniers les derniers parler d'un
préparatifs donc ça commence dès ce soir
et ça durera a priori jusqu'à samedi
tard dans la nuit absolument merci à
vous d'avoir été avec nous il nous reste
encore quelques jours d'été de bixente
dont il faut profiter et pour les
sorties en extérieur aux siens oui le
mois de septembre a été clément avec
nous un pour l'instant en tout cas on
touche du bois quoi de mieux donc de que
de se promener sous les rayons du soleil
et vous verrez qu'il ya des coins sympas
à faire dans les yvelines c'est notre
top 3 randonnées par célia 400 go
[Musique]
on
mais y en a une qui vous tente mais
chanter comme je suis un sportif moi je
vais tenter les 10 km départ et arrivée
à milon-la-chapelle 3h20 points samedi
après midi ça me convient bien alors
pour la fin de cette émission on en a
pris l'habitude pour cette deuxième
c'est aussi de vous annoncer les choses
en avance de prendre et bien d'autres
machines temporelle pour voir ce qu'il
se passe dans et bien les prochains
jours le week-end prochain avec au
programme les journées du patrimoine oui
le week-end prochain vous pourrez
retrouver de nombreuses animations
culturelles un peu partout dans les
yvelines on en a listé quelques-unes
grégory on va d'abord partir du sud pour
monter veulent moralement on ne demandez
pas pourquoi à rambouillet tout d'abord
ça va bouger tout le week-end à la
bergerie nationale
que vous soyez plutôt patrimoine
artistique avec la rencontre des
artistes en résidence historique il ya
des conférences et des ateliers autour
du patrimoine bâti aussi qu'ils soient
organisés y aura des ateliers nature et
découverte de la biodiversité et même du
patrimoine gourmand puisque des
dégustations accompagnées des
producteurs locaux sont prévus plein de
manières d'y trouver son compte et pour
ceux qui veulent tout faire vous pourrez
prendre votre temps puisque la
restauration sera possible sur place on
va aller à saint quentin en yvelines à
présent pareil ça va bouger dans toute
l'agglomération je vous recommande la
visite du château de la verrière à de
multiples aux horaires ce dimanche 19
septembre pensent à appeler avant pour
réserver d'ailleurs sinon ailleurs 200
cantons vous avez des animations à la
commanderie des visites du fort de saint
cyr du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ou du muet de
la médiathèque et le musée de la ville
de montigny le bretonneux notre petit
bas nous en sommes forcément dans la
cité royale alors on pense au château de
versailles mais il ya aussi l hôtel de
préfecture du département et qui sera
ouvert au public un l'hôtel de
département exactement l'hôtel de la
préfecture et du département le samedi
de 14 heures à 18 heures et le dimanche
de 10h à 18h également à noter que c'est
un petit hasard du calendrier mais les
jardins accueille en même temps des
béliers donc c'est pas une blague quand
vous verrez a vraiment un petit troupeau
des fenêtres des beaux salons versailles
et de l'hôtel alors on finit par un
petit bond dans le nord du département
cette fois ci un petit saut qui nous
emmène à mantes la jolie
là bas vous pourrez venir à la
découverte des différents monuments
religieux présents dans la ville des
visites guidées sont prévues à la
mosquée mende sud au temple protestant
de 1966 à la collégiale notre dame ou
encore au musée de l'hôtel dieu grégory
avec tous vos programmes du cou ou
est-ce que vos fans pour vous croisez
pendant les journées du patrimoine dont
j'avoue ne pas avoir encore tranché je
n'ai pas choisi ou est-ce que je vais
passer ses journées du patrimoine en
tout cas merci à bixente pour ce
programme très varié très dense 1 il ya
bien sûr d'autres choses encore mais
c'est votre sélection avec eux vous avez
proposé aux téléspectateurs de télé 78
ce soir merci bixente et d'avoir été
avec nous et c'est déjà la fin de cette
émission le 7-8 week-end qui revient
vendredi prochain sur tv 78 10 il a
passé un très bon week end
[Musique]